next on the agenda is event-driven
programs with Cloud functions
Cloud functions is serverless code that
lets you run it based on certain events
in this section we'll learn how it works
many applications contain event driven
parts for example maybe you have an
application that lets users upload
images
when that event takes place the image
might need to be processed in a few
different ways like converting the image
to a standard format converting a
thumbnail into different sizes
and storing each new file in a
repository
you can integrate this function into
your application
but then you'd have to provide compute
resources for it whether it happens once
a millisecond or once a day
with Cloud functions you could write a
single purpose function that completes
the necessary image manipulations and
then arrange for it to automatically run
whenever a new image is uploaded
Cloud functions is a lightweight
event-based asynchronous compute
solution that allows you to create small
single purpose functions that respond to
Cloud events without needing to manage a
server or a runtime environment
you can use these functions to construct
applications from bite-sized business
logic
you can also use cloud functions to
connect and extend cloud services
you are billed to the nearest 100
milliseconds but only while your code is
running
individual Cloud functions are written
in JavaScript node.js
python or go and executed in a
managenode.js environment on Google
Cloud
events from cloud storage and Pub sub
can trigger Cloud functions
asynchronously or you can use HTTP
invocation for synchronous execution